you know how like people say like
protect
[ __ ] yadda yadda at all costs or
whatever that's a thing you know like we
must protect cat protect cat williams at
all costs because he said something
about [ __ ]
suge knight
or tupac you know
this uh
whatever the opposite is
do that to matthew mcconaughey
you know what i mean
like
uh look the guys are phenomenal can be a
phenomenal actor okay let's say that can
be a phenomenal actor like no hate on
the matthew mcconaughey shits now let's
get into some comedy because they will
be like dude dude i did the [ __ ] i
posted my my clip about making fun of
jay-z it's like it's so stupid it's just
a silly [ __ ] rap lyric bit that i i
literally went on stage and they were
playing jay-z so i started talking about
it and people are like bro don't
disrespect the [ __ ] i'm all right
dude you know it's like
okay all right
cool i won't disrespect hov
okay cool yo dude not cool not cool to
disrespect one of the gr
you know
hanging into like in dudes no way
don't call me gay
it's all good but i'm not
whatever the opposite of the protect
yada yada at all costs is of matthew did
you know our national bird
the bald eagle yeah
its primary purpose in life is to build
a better
nest
i don't know why but i like that
i
thought he said something
so
[ __ ]
show-stopping
thought he said something so
[ __ ]
groundbreaking
thought he said something
so
[ __ ]
jaw-dropping thought he said something
so
[ __ ]
[Music]
pants-shitting
did you know our
the potential the potential of it the
potential of it like the potential of it
is the potential scale
is to build a better
net potential skill potential skill
i don't know why but i like that
oh potential scale [ __ ] absolutely
destroyed when he said nothing
i don't know
why is he sitting in grass taller than
him
dude he's sitting in a [ __ ] drinking
this this is a commercial dude don't be
had
dude
staring at his bourbon like
hey bro are you lex luthor
are you professor axe
did you know our national bird the bald
eagle
its primary purpose in life is to build
a better
nest
its primary purpose in life is to build
a better
nest
[Laughter]
but i like that
dude unbelievable man
unbelievable
this guy dude just
just [ __ ] eating his own [ __ ] you
know and just loving it come on over i
wouldn't be surprised if [ __ ] in a
year and a half honestly matthew kind of
has a huge event and he saved up all
like his excrement all year and he's
just like it's matthew mcconaughey [ __ ]
eating uh [ __ ]
extravaganza everybody come on by it's
it's not even invite only you can come i
don't care just he might eat my [ __ ] man
i've been doing it for years you just
come in you just eat my [ __ ] man right
it doesn't even stink here come in here
look at this you got a plate of [ __ ]
right there and i don't know why i don't
like that you're taking this
eating it look dip your finger in there
i don't know why but i like that i'm you
know i'm from texas
yeah longhorns man book them or whatever
the [ __ ] you know
buck em boys
baylor or whatever the [ __ ]
hook em hook em [ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em ride radham cowboys or
whatever the [ __ ] sayings are in
texas
why [ __ ] a dude when you could [ __ ]
ride a horse or whatever the [ __ ] it is
i don't know
why why barrel why [ __ ] uh hey we
welcome to matthew khan hey [ __ ] eating
extravaganza
the guy just [ __ ] so you know what he
is dude oh wow i just realized he's
armenian
dude he is
he is
a hundred percent armenian dude
this is so something a [ __ ] armenia
would do say
hey hey hey eat all your food or you'll
have an ugly wife dog
[Laughter]
hey do you know the hey do you know that
the national bird
[Laughter]
hey come here dog
where what was it again hold on let me
where's the clip [ __ ] i [ __ ] it up god
damn it
a dog a dog
the national it the national bird dog
did you know our national bird the bald
eagle oh its primary purpose in life is
to a dog a a b a for real though hey put
that down hey hey dog the national bird
the bald eagle hey look at look at nema
hey the national bird enima come here
hey listen to me doug armand
the national ironman put that down hey
listen to me the national
is the national bird eh the national
bird
um
the bald eagle dog a nema and armin put
that down
is actually um
their main purpose is to build a better
nest
i like that bro
hey nema
put that down dog
why is nemo always picking [ __ ] up dog
hey armand armand and nemo speaking [ __ ]
up though
i mean [ __ ] you dude this is unreal man
matthew mcconaughey is so unreal dude
i don't know why but i like that dog
welcome to the [ __ ] eating
[Laughter]
welcome to the [ __ ] eating contest
welcome to the matthew mcconaughey
welcome to the armin and nema [ __ ]
eating extravaganza dog
wow
we love it
i gotta wait wait wait wait wait wait
we're gonna watch this other one dude
here we go we gotta watch this other one
we gotta watch this other one that i had
on the [ __ ]
r2d2
i don't think that should have ever got
us time we gotta keep that okay we gotta
keep it weak
enough
a sense of humor was the default emotion
not an emotion i think the world would
be a lot better place
say evil
can't
tourette's dude tourette's dude
it is
not an emotion oh god you know you know
he just [ __ ] was
just winking
dude how annoying would it be with him
you want to go out you want to go mile
out and just sit in some chairs and
stare at bourbon and i'll just talk to
you i'll say some really important [ __ ]
until it crumbles
what
stop winking i don't know i just think
that it shouldn't ever go out of style
okay
yeah and whistling too you know since
the humor was a default emoji a dog
nema put that down hey hey his sense of
humor was the default a dog hey armand
oh my god
imagine a guy whistling and winking all
the time
never go out of sight sir old fashioned
um yeah so anyway
wow uh
god mathematically saw the kind of guy
that would like buy a [ __ ] car that
was so old and come in and show his
buddies and be like hey guys i did a
thing
[Laughter]
hey fellas i did a thing
i did a thing bought an old horse look
at that huh
close to death about two years ago we
fed it and we raised it oh boy i did a
thing crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]